SANDEEP DINESH: If
you're like most people,
chances are you're
using sources that
live outside of your cluster.
For example, maybe you're
using the Taleo API
to send text messages, or maybe
the Google Cloud Vision API
to do image analysis.
If you use the same endpoint
in all of your environments
and have no plans to bring the
servers into your Kubernetes
cluster, it's perfectly fine
to use the service endpoint
directly in your code.
However, there
are many scenarios
where this is not the case.
In this episode of
"Kubernetes Best Practices,"
let's learn how to leverage
the built-in service discovery
mechanisms inside Kubernetes for
services outside the cluster,
just like you can for
services inside the cluster.
One common service that's a good
example of an external service
is a database running outside
of your Kubernetes cluster.
While some cloud-native
databases, such as Google Cloud
Data Store or Google
Cloud Spanner,
use a single endpoint
for all access,
most databases have
separate endpoints
for different instances.
However, best practices
for traditional databases,
like MySQL and MongoDB,
usually prescribe
that you connect to
the different instances
for different environments.
So you might have a big
machine for production data
and maybe a little one
for the test environment.
But each of these will have a
different IP address or domain
name, and you don't
want to change
your code from environment
to environment.
So instead of hard-coding
these addresses,
you can actually use
the built-in Kubernetes
DNS-based service discovery
for these external services
just like you can for
native Kubernetes services.
OK, so let's say you're running
a MongoDB database on Google
Compute Engine.
So hopefully at
some point you can
bring a database
inside the cluster,
but until then, you're
stuck in this hybrid world.
Thankfully, you can use
static Kubernetes services
to ease some of the pain.
So in this example, I
created a MongoDB server
using Google Cloud Launcher.
So because it's created in
the same network, or VPC,
as the Kubernetes
cluster, it can
be accessed using the
high-performance internal IP
address.
In Google Cloud, this
is the default setup,
so there's nothing special
you need to configure.
So now we have the IP address.
The first step is
to create a service.
You may notice that there's no
pod selectors for this service.
So this will create a
service, but it really
won't know where to
send the traffic.
This allows you
to manually create
the endpoints object
that'll receive traffic
from the service.
You can see that the
endpoints manually
defines the IP address
for the database,
and it uses the same
name as a service.
Kubernetes will use
all the IP addresses
to find the endpoints as if they
were regular Kubernetes pods.
So now you can
access the database
with a simple connection string.
No need to use IP addresses
in your code at all.
If the IP addresses
change in the future,
you can just update the
endpoints with the new IP
addresses, and your applications
won't need to make any changes.
If you're using a hosted
database from a third party,
chances are they give you a
URI that you can connect to.
If they give you an IP
address, you can just
use the previous method.
So in this example, I
have two MongoDB databases
hosted on mLab.
One of them is by dev database,
and the other is production.
The connection strings for
these databases are as follows.
Now, mLab gives you a
dynamic URI and dynamic port.
And so you can see that
they're both different.
Let's use Kubernetes
to abstract over this.
So let's connect to
the dev database.
You can create an external
name Kubernetes service
which will give you
a static Kubernetes
service that redirects traffic
to the external service.
This service will do a
simple CNAME redirect
at the kernel level so
there's very minimal impact
on your performance.
So now you can use a much more
simplified connection string.
But because external name
uses a CNAME redirection,
it can't do port remapping.
So this may be OK with
services with static ports,
but unfortunately it falls
short in this example
where the port is dynamic.
mLab's free tier gives
you a dynamic port number,
and you can't change it.
This means you need a
different connection
string for development
and production,
and you need to hard-code values
for the port, which is bad.
So how can we get port
remapping to work?
The first step is to get
the IP address from the URI.
If you run nslookup,
hostname, or the ping command
against the URI, you can get
the IP address of the database.
Now you have the IP address.
If the service gives you
back multiple IP addresses,
you can actually use all of
them in the endpoints object.
The key thing to remember
is that IP addresses
behind the URI can
change without notice.
This method is kind of
risky to use in production
if you aren't sure the
IP address won't change.
With this, you can connect
to the remote database
without needing to
specify the port.
Kubernetes service transparently
does the port remapping.
So mapping external
sources to internal ones
gives you the flexibility
to bring these services
into the cluster in the
future while minimizing
refactoring efforts.
Even if you don't plan on
bringing them in today,
you never know what
tomorrow brings.
It also makes it easier
to manage and understand
what external services
your organization is using.
I'll see you on the next episode
of "Kubernetes Best Practices."
[MUSIC PLAYING]